I heard that you said Rocky couldn't
have existed without Carl weather right
no I you know it first of all Rocky's a
I know look at that boot it's so iconic
wow yeah yeah yeah he was
amazed I couldn't find anyone to play
the part no one had all the tools either
the voice was too high or they weren't
big enough or they weren't athletic
enough it's really hard to find yeah
everything in a person so it was about
8:00 at night and the guy I wanted that
he quit because he wants to go in a
bicycle race competition went really so
obviously he was not a serious actor
yeah he was a physical type so I'm
sitting there and at 8:30 this fella
comes in and he's mad like what am I
here for I mean cuz no one gets like you
don't have an audition at 8:30 at night
you're like at the bottom of the barrel
you know what I mean you know what I
mean it's like lunch it's like 8:30 so
he comes in they pulled him off a plane
going to Oakland so he's coming and he's
fired up all right what do I do I go
voice good voice is good go check that
he go and he takes his jacket off
shoulders forever check check and then
he look I went good looking y yeah nice
I didn't expect that you know cuz he's a
boxer and then we start and tough then
we started to get up I'm telling you he
goes pow
poww damn like it's like a woodpecker
hit me oh my God act and then he goes I
would have done better if you at least
hired a real actor instead of uh what do
you what's this guy do work in the
office I no he's Rocky it all right how
you doing Rock like
there and I go it's gu arrogant got
it but you need it you know what I mean
I wanted that I wanted him to have this
like Muhammad Ali he had it all he had
charm he had this he had heart he had
Soul so I I was stunned when it happened
I was like Crush I didn't think he would
ever die you know he's like Superman
yeah yeah so I look back now with fine
fine fine memories because it's never
going to happen you know when have you
have those seminal moments those
Crossroads it's like certain chemistry
on certain it's impossible to duplicate
you know it's like if they take a group
let's say the Rolling Stones right you
take Mick Jagger out it's over yeah you
take Mick Jagger a solo I don't think it
works either there's something about
that combination that was so unique that
you can't you can't mess with it yeah
and I think that happened with Rocky
everybody in it was like sort of Born to
play the part yeah hey I love and when
it works out like that that's why it's
so successful yeah it is it
[Music]
[Applause]
is thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home